I'm waiting for the 2011 Nobel Prize in
Chemistry I have no idea who's won by
well-prepared I've got my tie of Nobel
Prize winners of chemistry and I've got
my Nobel Prize medal chocolates
I'm not sure what's happening
The Times hit zero and we're waiting and
you can see the journalist on the video
trying to make up something to say
because nothing's happened oh here they
come
me tea professor Daniel Schiffman they
take new Israeli Institute of Technology
- this sounds very interesting but I'm
not really awareness work at all so
let's see what it's about this prize is
really quite exciting
and something I don't know much about
but I think it's probably not too hard
to explain but I need a few models so
just wait a moment
yeah surprised very very surprised I
must admit that the Nobel Prize for
chemistry this year has gone to
quasicrystals that's physics sorry but
it's physics sometimes the there are
these traditional boundaries between
physics and chemistry that are a bit
annoying because I do I work on surfaces
much my work you could describe as
physical chemistry or chemical physics
or physics sometimes or chemistry I'm
interested in how things bond i things
bond and the properties of solids you
know some of that is solid-state physics
some of its solid-state chemistry enough
dividing line is very difficult but the
the Nobel Prize for quasi crystals you
know is I I think incredibly well
deserved they revolutionized our
understanding of matter of how matter
behaves revolutionized our understanding
what a crystal is the price has been won
by an Israeli scientists called Daniel
Schechtman who works in Israel though at
the time he made the discovery for which
he's got the prize he was visiting the
National Bureau of Standards in America
and the prize is for discovery of
something that is called quasi crystals
quasi means is a poss way of saying sort
of if it's quasi crystal what's a
crystal crystal is a regular pattern of
atoms and here you can see is a
sort of archetypal example of a crystal
where each item has a very fixed
relationship with his neighbors and you
can define a unit cell you can define a
basic periodic unit that you can repeat
the whole way through the crystal the
discovery which is really quite unusual
can be dated to a particular time on a
particular morning usually a Nobel Prize
is for a body work that has been
developed over many years but this
discovery was discovered early in the
morning of the 8th of April 1982 because
Daniel Schechtman wrote it down in his
notebook his lab notebook it shows the
importance if you don't write your
results in your lab notebook you might
not get the Nobel Prize so make that a
warning to you fact the discovery of
quasi crystals means that we've had
actually changed the definition of what
a crystal is what he was doing it was he
was studying a crystal of a mixture of
alumina which is a aluminium oxide and
the manganese oxide and mixed oxides he
was studying this with high-resolution
electron microscopy so this is looking
at it almost in this atomic level
but he was looking these crystals in a
mode with a microscope the way the
microscope was working there's called
electron diffraction where you get a
pattern that shows the symmetry of the
crystal
for example this thing here has
threefold symmetry if I rotate it
through 120 degrees it looks the same
what he discovered in this experiment
which is that his crystal had apparently
ten fold symmetry that means you could
rotate it ten times before you got it
back to where it started and the reason
people got so excited all was so
skeptical to begin with was because of
the nature of crystals and something
which many of you may have done when you
were at primary school when you were
trying to make patterns with tiles when
you make patterns with tile
if you have triangular tiles which have
threefold symmetry or squares or
hexagons you can cover the whole piece
of paper so that's our basic repeating
unit so we can tile the plane let's put
those together without leaving any gaps
and if I cut these a little bit more
cleverly there wouldn't be any gaps but
you get the idea we can tile the plane
periodic and the teacher will say well
done to you but if you use a fivefold
symmetry
that's a Pentagon if you start trying to
stick them down and cover the paper you
get into a terrible mess okay you can
immediately see where we've got a
problem because now we can't fit this
Pentagon in and we have to go over here
perhaps and over here but again you can
see that we're leaving gaps so it was
thought for centuries a long long time
if you've got one a crystal here on
something that's periodic and repeating
fivefold symmetry temporal symmetry is
out and until this morning of the 8th of
April 1982 everyone believed that you
couldn't have fivefold symmetry because
the structure could not repeat over and
over again just like the titling of the
floor or the tiling on your paper which
didn't please the teacher well why did
he get so excited he saw this in there
in the diffraction pattern the
diffraction pattern tells us about the
symmetry and it was a crystal but yet it
had this symmetry which if it's fivefold
a temple you just can't you can't fill
the lattice you can't fill the planar
you can't fill a space you have to leave
gaps and yes so there are you know in a
multitude of different ways and so
eventually it turned out that his
crystal was an example of what is known
in maths as Penrose tiling this is where
you can get what appears to be a regular
pattern but it never exactly repeats
itself and if it doesn't repeat itself
then you can get away with fivefold
symmetry instead of using one tile like
that and this was sort of discovered
afterwards
and this is a Penrose tiling and there
are a whole family of different tilings
but the simplest one you can have are
these rhombi which have different angles
I'd like to be able to put this all
together in front of you but it would
take me some time sort of done as I've
downloaded this and this is that this is
a rhombus tiling just last week Friday
last week just a few days ago I was at
the University of Western Australia in
Perth in their chemistry building I've
got a picture of it here
and this chemistry building has in its
atrium its entrance hall the largest
floor in the world with Penrose tiling
and I was looking at it and thinking how
strange it was and I took a photo and
didn't realize that this was going to be
relevant the Nobel Prize a few days
later what's the relationship between
this and quasi crystals the important
thing is in quasi crystals you can if
you imagine that these tiles represent
the arrangement of atoms in a crystal by
tiling these tiles you can build up
something that looks like this and
what's wrong absolutely gobsmacking
about this is that it is perfect
long-range order but it's not periodic
the whole of the argument depends on
rotational symmetry the number of times
you can rotate something till you get
back to where you started and he saw in
the diffraction pattern ten spots which
could either mean you could rotate it
ten times or possibly five before you
got back to the same place you started
but I've attained all fivefold symmetry
was completely unacceptable for a
crystal structure at the time he made
the discovery the important thing with
the Crossley crystals is it affects our
understanding of crystals and how matter
behaves in general right across the
board that's the reason he's won the
Nobel Prize because it's completely
changed our understanding even for those
people who don't work in quasi crystals
I don't work in cross the crystals I've
never done working cause because though
I am a surface physicist and spend a lot
of my time thinking about periodicity of
atoms and molecules and services this
when I first came to know about it just
really is
is so weird to have long-range order
without translation periodicity it's
more that the widening of our
understanding of what it is to be a
crystal basically like everything in
chemistry when somebody discovers
something that makes you think makes you
change your ideas it's really important
so I think to celebrate this Nobel Prize
I'll share the chocolate with Brady so
here's to you